every semi-automatic weapon used in the
terrorist attack on Friday will be
banned in this country New Zealand's
assault weapons ban comes a week after
that deadly terrorist attack on two
mosques Democrats immediately praised
the response and push for similar action
here in the United States Bernie Sanders
tweeted this is what real action to Stop
gun violence looks like we must follow
New Zealand's lead and Alexandre Koster
Cortez also chimed in saying within days
New Zealand acted to get weapons of war
off the consumer market this is what
leadership looks like joining me now
someone uniquely qualified to address
this issue House Minority Whip Steve
Scalise a gun violence victim himself
congressman you heard Bernie you heard
AOC praising the leadership of New
Zealand saying let's get it done here
are they right well Lawrence the first
thing that we all should do is keep in
mind that there are 50 victims and we
should pray for them but when you hear
liberals in Washington talking about gun
control
it's much less about guns and much more
about control if you look they've been
trying to control every aspect of
people's lives just a few weeks ago that
passed a bill to take away First
Amendment rights everybody from the ACLU
to National Right to Life said they were
infringing on the First Amendment rights
then a few weeks before that they passed
a bill to take away some more of your
Second Amendment rights the law and
we're talking about law-abiding citizens
here we're not talking about people that
are out committing these crimes already
violating laws that are on the books
enforce the laws that are out there but
don't infringe upon the rights of
law-abiding citizens unfortunately
that's what Democrats want to do and
watch we have a Second Amendment in this
in this case they're very different
countries we've had our share of
terrible gun violence obviously that is
reprehensible and horrific so they point
to high-capacity magazines you got to
get those off the street no reason to
have an ar-15 isn't they are 15 one of
the most popular you know rifles in the
United States I mean that's a lot of
weapons you'll have to confiscate I
guess if that's what they want to do
Laura this is the danger of what they're
trying to do when you look at their
definition of semi-automatic weapons and
by the way automatic weapons have
already been banned since 1986
semi-automatic weapons
when they describe them in many cases
they're talking about hunting rifles
they're talking about weapons that
people buy to defend themselves in their
home these aren't the weapons in many
cases that are being used in some of
these violent crimes and so we have a
second Amendment for a reason and that's
so people can defend themselves against
criminals yeah I want to play something
that happened with Ali Velshi like over
there at MSNBC
and Dana Millbank let's watch those
somewhere else with this because nobody
in America suggested banning any guns
but we have so many guns in this country
that it causes other problems right
while mass shootings get our attention
because they're so they're so tragic we
live in a different system we have
constitutional obstacles but it is
outrageous that all we hear you know
it's become as cliche thoughts and
prayers it's not doing anything to stop
this from happening it constitutional
obstacles it's not how I view them
listen to what they say they they view
the Constitution as an obstacle that
they can go around the Constitution is a
framework of our country what it's what
makes us in America better than
everybody else in the world in terms of
a country where you actually have rights
that are given to you not from men and
women but from God and you have those
rights for a reason so that you can
protect yourself in your home and I I'm
happy to take all the thoughts and
prayers that I I can get every day and
I'm giving them I need to go starts in
the Prairie and they meant a lot to me
they sure did and we were praying for
you and we continued to congressman
thank you so much